he was a symbol of courage and
resilience
and now he's the latest publicly known
casualty of this pandemic
captain tom moore a world war ii veteran
who collected millions of pounds to
support the british health sector
in its fight against kovite 19. now sir
tom has succumbed to the virus himself
and britons are bidding him farewell
[Applause]
but most kobit 19 deaths happen in
obscurity
far away from the public eye and often
without a proper send-off
more than 2.2 million people have died
from the coronavirus worldwide
so far some countries even have to
create new space for the graves
many cemeteries are like assembly lines
of wakes and funerals
[Music]
the pandemic has made one of the most
traumatic experiences in a person's life
even harder to cope with
to our kirby 19 special i'm monica jones
and i have to say those
images are hard to bear but that's
the reality millions are living with
since the start of this pandemic
the death toll is overwhelming also for
those whose job it is
to give the deceased a dignified
send-off
there should be a moment of prayer but
there's no time
for that there are simply too many
coffins
too many bodies arriving at the dubain
crematorium in saxony
and some days there are more bodies than
we can actually cremate on a single day
this is strenuous for our employees also
because there's no end in sight
unfortunately we had to convert the hall
into a storage space
because we could no longer keep up with
the deaths
[Music]
it's a difficult situation for us
because relatives can usually say
goodbye to their loved ones here
but at the moment that's not possible
no room for a funeral service not all of
the coffins represent deaths from the
coronavirus but many of them are marked
so
these people had to end their lives
without a final hug
from their loved ones
lutz bearish cares for the bereaved he
is a pastor in durban
families sometimes only realize how
dangerous the coronavirus can be
once they've lost a loved one to it
i have contact with families who have
lost a relative because of coven 19.
they're in a state of shock and
reconsidering things
this first phase of mourning the
so-called shock phase
lasts longer for them because something
inexplicable
something incomprehensible has been
added namely
this pandemic
the pandemic is far from over
many more cremations will be carried out
here
gerald munster is worried about the
future
assuming that the number of infections
remains high
it follows that the number of deaths
will too
and that means we won't see any relief
here until
mid-february at the earliest
it is a winter of morning in durban as
it is in many places in the world during
the pandemic
thorsten benkel is a thanatologist at
the university of pasa which means that
he engages in the academic study of
death and
dying and he joins us now good to have
you with us uh now people die
all the time we all know that but is
losing a loved one now during this
pandemic
harder than normally or is that just our
perception
well i think it's hard all the time it
doesn't really matter what the
circumstances are if you lose a loved
one
you you deal with different things than
just the cause of death
i mean of course it's tragic to have a
pandemic and so many people die it's the
sheer mass that
really makes us feel uncomfortable when
reading the news
but for the families for the bereaved
ones i don't think it really matters so
much
but i mean the difficult part of
mourning and i know that from personal
experience is the part of letting go and
that
is usually helped by rituals and
ceremonies that can't take place now
how can we compensate for that to help
us get closure
well that's true the problem is that the
panemic uh has some
effects on all those rituals you can
still have rituals of course
but you cannot have the traditional way
of letting go
in in a burial for instance and you
cannot
talk to the funeral directors in a way
that you
could do before a corona struck us
um people nowadays tend to
individualize their morning more than
they did
decades ago so for some not much changes
because if they
if i lose a loved one i will treat this
problem in my very personal and own way
so i don't need those collective rituals
that's the one perspective
but the other perspective is people say
i need the
usual the traditional surrounding i need
the traditional rituals i need a
you know i need a way to let go that is
that has traditional bonds with
everything that i've learned from my
childhood on
how we treat the dead and those people
are really desperate because
they cannot have what they are used to
or what they expect
from letting go and
losing someone they love i talked i
talked to some people who said i wanted
to go to the funeral
director and all i got was an email link
and i should do everything online and
type in what my wishes are and no one
was willing to talk to me in person
and i just have to pay then and just
we do it on a written basis and for them
it was really terrible
right i mean and they need something
death is an extremely personal
experience as personal as it can get
if we turn sides let's talk about those
on the other side i mean
how important is it for a dying person
to have family or friends around because
this is something that a lot of those
who are left behind
really grapple with yeah that's true
most people that die and i consciously
know i am dying
for instance in hospice or maybe of
cancer or something like that
most people want their loved ones with
them their family their friends their
partners their children
that's the usual ways very small
minorities say
no i don't want them with me because i
don't want to you know
give them an impression of a loved
person dying and having these
these pictures in their minds forever
but this is a minority most people
feel more comfortable and due to the
pandemic
this is not or not as much possible as
it used to be
in the first round in uh in the spring
of 2020
um they had a lockdown even on those
hospices um
people were not allowed only one person
was allowed to attend or to visit
someone
this has now changed in many parts of
germany at least
but still it's far from being perfect
because you know if you want to see
someone who's about to die you don't
really
it's not the first thing on your mind is
the hygienic elements of it
or the rules that come with it you just
want to be with this person it's an
emotional matter and
emotional matters are not really cannot
be compensated by rational measures
how important is a ceremony not just for
us as individuals
but for society as a whole
well you know society needs rituals and
ceremonies
because they are a symbolic
frame so to speak for living together
you know instead for instance a burial
it doesn't really care
it doesn't really matter what the
diseased person thinks about it because
that person is dead
and it's done for purposes of showing
solidarity
to all the other people that still live
the
the people that the relatives and the
neighbors they
show and present themselves to attend
the funeral
so that we all know we stand together we
are united even if we are usually not
that's the main the core idea of a
burial ritual
nowadays in individualized society it's
become
a bit different though of course but
it's it's it's also i mean now this
pandemic that's why it's called a
pandemic
uh there are more than two million dead
around the globe
and we've hardly had national memorials
so far
only recently u.s president joe biden uh
uh
one year into the pandemic actually held
a memorial for more than four hundred
thousand americans who died of kovit 19.
other countries including germany
haven't done any of that yet
why not isn't that important
well um actually it's not the usual way
and how this is how a dynamic is treated
usually
national memorials are done at least
german perspective is
if famous people die everyone knows and
if they have a
really big um you know big
famous politicians have had impact on
the country
and pandemic has nameless victims it's
hard to say but really
it's average people that die not famous
people and it's unusual
sometimes you have the churches who do
something like that they
will do that once it's over i guess we
will then reflect on what has happened
and there will be some rituals some
symbolic gestures
but it is not something that society
really demands
it's purely symbolic it doesn't help the
relatives who lost someone
i mean it's a harsh perspective maybe
that i'm taking as a scientist
but really it doesn't help much and
people realize more
and more once more in an individualized
society that we don't need those
collective rituals
rather people prefer personal individual
rituals
that really put the person lost in the
spectrum in the in the center and not
everyone who died because those hundred
thousands or millions who died
you know pers i don't know any of those
and
even if i know three or four or five the
others are not important for my life
you can't relate it's hard to say about
that
no one can't really really relate to
them we all read the news and say it's
terrible so many people died
but for us it's a number for most people
it's just a number
we don't really get the scope anyway if
you hear two million dead
you can't even imagine what two million
people are if you see them at one place
from from a helicopter two million
people and you realize they are all
there that would be terrible but we
don't have that perspective
exactly you just say that we read about
it every day and we say it's terrible
it's quite interesting actually and
i've heard it from other people as well
and it happens to me that
i've been reading those uh daily death
statistics now for weeks and weeks
and it starts to no longer really bother
me
is that worrying or is that normal
yeah that's absolutely normal that's
exactly what happens
in the first weeks or months people are
really terrified oh i can't get this
disease and i could die and my
loved ones could die but we get in a
very uh
well uncomfortable way we get used to it
we don't like the idea of having
epidemic we want don't want to die but
it's the same every day you read those
statistics
every day and once it's more once it's
less corpses
but we get used to it people always get
used to any conditions they live in
and this is what happening what's
happening with a kobit right now
now this is of course not the very first
time that humanity faces
so many deaths in such a short period of
time we've had world wars we had the
spanish flu
we had various plagues are there any
learnings what do we know about
those crises and and how those affected
people and the way they were dealing
with death
well in the past the good thing about
those plagues was that
they were very uh they were they didn't
take place in a globalized world
you know you had specific regions mostly
sometimes quite big regions like
it was the whole of europe was affected
but nothing else then
and so in a way you could always cope
with them because once the dead people
were dead and the others were
trying to escape um the pandemic or the
plagues that we had they just cease to
exist they don't really cease to exist
but they become
you know you can control them and
they're very small outbreaks of them
now we have a pandemic that is
globalized because
you can go by plane from every place in
the world to every other place in a
short time
so that makes things difficult but the
good thing is humanity has always been
able to overcome
every plague or every uh deadly uh
sickness that was around and we will be
able to overcome
uh kovitz as well i'm absolutely sure
about that
problem is it will take more time and
different measures
because people today are much more
connected to each other
and they're not used to staying just in
one region and especially they're not
used
to die because we we live in the western
world we live in a society where
everyone says getting old it's the usual
uh case and dying young is not a huge
case when we had
uh in the middle ages you had to play
well people didn't bother
so much because they died anyways with
40 or so so dying with 30 wasn't
such a big topic yeah that was the time
when death was called
the tamed death because everybody knew
about dying it was an average
occurrence today death is something we
don't even want to think about
exactly we don't think about it much we
we certainly don't like to talk about it
everything is about
youth and eternal life uh but you
and this is uh the final question but i
have to ask you you decided
uh to dedicate your studies to well a
grim topic from uh today's views
why would someone choose to study death
well the answer is quite boring it's
just because it's interesting
you know i don't have a very personal uh
story about death and i'm
not really traumatic experiences that i
want to compensate with my
scientific uh doings no actually it is
interesting it's interesting to see
how people deal with it because everyone
sooner or later is affected it's
interesting to compare cultural
dealings with death and not many people
in my field of sociology do it so
it all speaks for um going for it and
that's what i'm doing for
10 years now well and that was very good
for us because we could talk to you
about it
torstenbanker sociologist and
phanetologist
thank you so much for your time my
pleasure
now of course to prevent as many cov19
deaths as possible
we turn to vaccines but the virus is not
making it easy
time for your questions now and over to
our science correspondent derek williams
wouldn't modifying vaccines due to new
variants be a huge undertaking
modifying vaccines would be a lot easier
and faster
in some ways than you might think but it
would still be
a pretty big deal most of the vaccines
approved so far
work by getting your cells to create
viral proteins so basically the shot
you're getting
contains genetic blueprints for example
in the form of
messenger rna which instructs your cells
to make the spike protein
that dots the outside of sars kobe 2. um
those proteins
provoke your immune system to recognize
the virus
without ever being exposed to it when
the spike protein changes
due to mutation making a new variant
more
transmissible for instance then in
theory
we can quickly figure out what's causing
the changes
at the genetic level and just update the
blueprint
in our vaccines to tell the body to
start making
a variant spikes in addition to the
original ones
so it's not all that complicated
theoretically but
but the reality of changing vaccine
production processes even a little
would pose some pretty major challenges
i think and makers
are facing enough of those at the moment
already
then there's the question of the kind of
trials that updated vaccines would have
to go through
to be considered safe and effective
would manufacturers have to start from
square one again
no probably not but but altered vaccines
would certainly have to go through some
testing so so
so changes would take months to
implement
um fortunately we have some experience
with this
overall situation flu vaccines
have to be updated regularly to remain
effective so at least there's a
framework in place
to help guide health care authorities
[Music]
back to captain tom moore he may be gone
but his legacy
lives on the super fundraiser has
inspired 11 year old footballer imogen
papworth heidel
she is using her skill at kippy uppies
the
tricky art of keeping the ball in the
air without letting it
touch the ground to raise thousands of
pounds for key workers
and she's also inspired others to use
their soccer skills
for a good cause shortly before he died
captain tom said
imogen's efforts were cool and we want
to leave you
with that thought